oh sorry run I'm so sorry red today
we're gonna play archery goal like
frisbee golf except instead of there
being a basket or a pole if the hit was
risky it's a person they hit with an
arrow now whoever has to take the most
shots here that person becomes the
flagpole for the next round you will get
hit with an arrow run you remember when
I said I needed you to be an integral
part of this video of course oh that's
what you meant I need you to put on the
wall though shirt and be the first
target let me get this straight
you're all going to take turns shooting
an arrow at me over and over yeah member
takes the most shots to get to you
becomes star for the second man I hope
Jake does poorly hahaha you bet I'm
super good at archery go down there
I ran peyote how do you want to
determine who goes first container Nico
let us begin chin chin chin chin to chin
chin none
chin chin three [ __ ] are you go digging
yeah there's a little kid out there
though he'll be fine I'm going to put
the mask on for this because there's so
far away all right didn't make it
halfway
that was
we got an ego firing it oh it's pretty
good thank you I wonder if they know
that they have to shoot the arrow at a
45 degree angle to maximize the distance
at physics that was weeks on Brett you
are away so please begin hope they don't
hit OB my wife would not be happy in
this but he actually came pretty close
the structure can turn off with that
[Music]
below is the birdie opportunity Ted it's
not get it removed
yeah
9n huh well you're fired for par baby
ginseng game
all right detention game to see who is
the unfortunate victim vigil game
attention works if you watch this now
you must play tension for life just like
in Rock Paper Scissors release the
rhythm we go one two three shoot the
favorite chin chin chin chin flank on
that beat you say a number I'm gonna go
with chin chin three and ever we get to
decide to put up either some those
thumbs are know some and if I say a
numbers it's equal to the number of
thumbs that pops up I lose one hand and
the first one to lose both hands wins
and you keep going until there's one
loser
ching-ching six chinches to think we
didn't do
all right chin chin to chin chin three
chin chin none can share one chin chin
none chin chin to chin chin one 10 10 -
10 10 1
whoa all right I gotta follow harmine a
part is how many shot it should take you
to get into the target flesh hole you
should take a copy to Archer for a shot
to get to the breath anomaly I'm not
gonna lose this game right through that
hole in the trees Oh bold strategy and
it looks like it'll paid although he's
almost there enough buddy my god oh
that's like when you try to go between
the sand trap and the pond then you hit
the sand trap
all right rent your GoPro rolling whoa
whoa was everything rolling oh that's in
the pond no other class in the pond baby
arrow yet you just fired it right there
on the tree Wren clearly hit the pond
Retin you're gonna have to take a drop
buddy drop put it behind you and drop it
wherever it lands for you shoot all
right brother back it is I can do this I
might be able to shoot it out of the
tree I hear you do it
hold on real quick real quick ready
Oh hold you you're going to lose another
one you have to bear hug it all the way
up yeah
French is standing on the field waiting
for us to show those players you've lost
two precious iron to the tree of debt
let us move on ready Brett oh good shot
looks like sorry brother
Oh Ren you're away sir
man triple dose terrific run waichman
for triple bogey Oh
Ren's tilting right now whoa that counts
barely we're all sportsmen here what do
we do we'll be at the target well Ren
unfortunately for you and fortunately
for me Nico and Brett you're now the
flagpole again we raise the stakes a
little bit plank pole will be on the
other side of the water I am doing both
Brett and Jake is going to put an arrow
into the water
what's update about we do a tactical
skill shot where you have to shoot it to
the edge and then shoot across now we're
going to lose our arrow parenting on
dude none of you guys have the control
to not overshoot I'll bet you I'll bet
you $10 I won't overshoot it I just saw
you overshoot it five minutes ago yeah I
know but I bet you on this one I won't
have a $10 $10
this is like a handshake between Trudeau
and I'm jump okay it's not back there
perfect get to the edge here and then
shoot over the water skill is the name
and game I'm gonna make 10 bucks in the
process the park who are three cars from
confidence levels hi I plan on just
taking a little bit of Niko's pride with
this one I can maybe aim for those trees
just hit the tree and I'll stop it right
there but I missed the tree it goes
right into the water so I could shoot it
up so it comes back down with no forward
momentum and hits the ground in front
more than anything else I don't want to
go into the water so that Jake can't
blow yeah I take no risk Niko safety
Parris this arrow here is worth $10 to
make oh I've tried it and I love to
change we're sick good show good show
Nikko are you going to go over yes yes
I'm moving you don't lose it in the
water okay great in the water oh wow
that is way more clearance than I
thought I'm you
whoo well Miguel you've earned $10
chicks whoo oh I don't have any cash on
me
ha ha ha I'm Ben Williams and a higher
bid for me cold draw Bulger I'll hold
her on there you go
whoo put the tree on the way over oh my
guys are so close yeah okay all right
[Music]
definitely and I made it across the pond
but I'm right in front of this tree do I
shoot over the next branch and under the
one after that
how do I temp you go over this one and
over that one and then under the white
tree I would go over too well Nico
that's where you and I different I'm
gonna go over both whoo I said bow II
but I will take it sir you're in all
right
Nico for par
oh I'm sorry I did not walk that time
yeah all right man yeah I've got the
twisting all over now
I didn't block it in time I thought I
was like oh no I told you I wouldn't
miss I've got good news and I've got bad
news good news is that we probably won't
hit you in the nuts again the bad news
is got two more shots coming at you now
that sting game Jeff
well Niko congratulations you won the
game but you still owe me ten dollars
but yeah we'll practice up and try this
again Ren thank you for being a great
port and make a great party let's go
stand back in the field and rank it -
one shot at each one of us to try to hit
us on what's really yeah concerned
there's only one helmet there's three of
us that's pretty good and if you're
gonna aim for me you're gonna have to
aim a little better tell you right now
this also must have been what it was
like going into battle whoo I definitely
feel bad for Ren it sucks getting shot
at with arrows and also for all of our
ancestors who got shot at and days of
yore yeah this video is dedicated to
those guys like I killed an arrow for
real
Oh
quarter
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]